welcome back everyone to dc thursday
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and
data community fund and we have another
amazing guest lined up today
in our series of uh uh interesting
people who have
been foundationally um instrumental and
helpful in building the data ecosystem
and uh today i'm excited to have julian
ledem
with us uh he's the co-founder and cto
of datakin
currently but julian has also been
involved in some
instrumental projects that we all know
and
many most of us use um he's the
co-author of
parquet she's been very involved in
the development of apache arrow as a pmc
member
and previously he worked at wework at
dremeo
as a staff staff software engineer at
twitter as a principal engineer at yahoo
and he studied math math physics
and cs in france so julian
i want to welcome you to the show and
thanks for for being on with us today
well thanks for having me
so the first question that i just wanted
to ask you and i hope
i hope this is okay is you've been in
the industry for so long
i think you came to the us maybe in 2006
or seven is that about right
2007 yeah 2007. so you've been involved
in so many instrumental projects
i was just wondering why it's taking you
so long to start a company in
in the data world well yeah i think
you know it's funny at the same time it
took a long time but it feels like
everything i've done so far kind of led
into this into
um building a data platform
building open source projects um
and really creating communities and
becoming part of this community of this
data community
and understanding it better it's kind of
all led to
um to that point in really
how do we solve um depending on each
other
and like operating data platform and
data pipeline at scale and when i say at
scale it's not like just big data scale
like a lot of data but it's
really today's like organizational scale
right where you have lots of teams and
people depending on each other producing
and consuming data
so it kind of i feel like a lot of
things that i've
done in the past led to this point and
it's kind of
because i've been involved and because
i've
started open source projects and i've
helped grow
others that i got there right
well it's a definitely it's a blessing
when you see that your career
has when you look back over your
shoulder and you see that your career
has had a series of steps that
have actually been joined to an apparent
productive and and and
uh i i know the feeling and so um i'm
glad that you that you have that sense
as well
so so let's talk about some of these key
moments because
i find my conversations with founders
that it's
it's often understanding what those key
moments were and what the key insights
were along their way in their career
um that definitely have sort of led them
to
to where they ended up um during our
conversation and so
we're going to have some awesome chats
later about
open lineage metadata some other things
but
um you know you have such an amazing
journey
from company to company that were
significant in the data space i just
wanted to
stop along the way and chat about some
of those experiences so
maybe we can start at yahoo because i
think yahoo is likely your first
meaningful
data job if i'm not mistaken yeah that's
correct so it's like the company i was
working for
back in the day got acquired by yahoo
and so
i ended up working for yao and so in
2007 i moved to the
headquarters and
started i joined that team who was
building platforms on top of
hadoop for the more media
uh companies of yao so you know like
yahoo shopping
yeah news yeah movies yeah autos
a lot of those things so we do a lot of
collecting um listings or news articles
or used cars listings or different
things like that and so there's lots of
text processing matching
products to catalogs matching
you know extracting entities for news
articles and bringing structures to all
those listings and these
uh articles or like movie description
and bringing that structure and that
kind of helped build this guided
navigation
um and that you would find in a shopping
comparison engine for example and
so that so on so it's kind of building a
generic platforms for those kinds of
properties on top of hadoop
and of course at the time yahoo was kind
of the place to be
to use hadoop right that was really the
beginning of hadoop and i remember
seeing i was in the same building as the
hadoop team at some point and
seeing hadoop team members with the
t-shirt that was
saying in the back scaling hadoop to 20
nodes right you know
that's what's going up and to the right
uh and it was like
20 nodes yeah um
so that those were the days and of
course like um over those four years
those that was maybe an old t-shirt
already at the time but
it's kind of of course it was like
thousands of nodes
by the end of it um and so
at the time we were building you know
how do we do batch processing and this
transformation and this
enrichment on top of hadoop and it's
kind of you end up with
many teams you know consuming and
producing data you have like these
different
properties and different teams depending
on each other
and you start thinking about how do we
apply the
service oriented architecture principles
for this kind of batch processing
because now the interface
is not a service api right it's a data
set
right the interface is a data set and
the data sets at the time
they are shared in a distributed file
system you know you have the hadoop
distributed file system and so there's a
folder somewhere
in a shared file system that is shared
with some other team
and the if this is the only thing you do
and you said oh people write files to
the file system and share it with others
it becomes a big mess right you need
ways to coordinate
to trigger a downstream consumption when
a data set is updated
all those mechanisms that now we're kind
of you know more used to with warfare
engines
and so for me that was the beginning of
thinking really okay how do we define
those service oriented architecture
principles what are the interfaces
how do we depend on each other how do we
trigger downstream transformation how
are we aware of
the age of data set and that's kind of
kind of thing that
started this and also you know at start
at the time i started contributing to
pig
because at the time you know we were
still writing raw mapreduce jobs
at the time and pig was a better
mapreduce
and it's kind of piggy has kind of lost
momentum since then but at the time it
was a better map producer it's kind of
the niche that sparked took over now now
spark is the better mapreduce and kind
of
uh really out lasted every other
competitor in that space
at the time pig was big and uh and there
was a strong community around it
uh like in particular with obviously
yahoo who started the project
netflix linkedin and twitter and it's
kind of that's what led me to my next
job right like
a big committer that was my first
commentership
the apache project um because you went
to you went to twitter next right and
then you
um you worked in the data team at
twitter in maybe 2012
or so 2011 okay
twitter end of 2011 and that was through
this community right through
uh the peak community i met the data
teams at uh netflix
uh linkedin twitter and i decided to
join twitter at that time
and so i twitter yes i joined the data
team so in that sense that was more the
traditional way people
think about big data they think about
time series
you know we know about how people are
using your product what they click on
what they search
for and things like that and so lots of
time series data everything collected on
hadoop
um and at the time you know
twitter had hadoop clusters that were
able to store a lot of data
but of course you know when you run a
pig job or a mapreduce job you know
you go take a coffee and you come back
later right so it's kind of optimized
for throughput but not for latency
from the user perspective so it's kind
of can process a lot of data
uh can store a lot of data but it's kind
of slow iteration for analysts or
data scientists or people kind of trying
to figure out what the data is
and they also add which is a data
warehouse so it's more like
sql lower latency but of course
it didn't scale as well as hadoop right
so it would always have a fraction
of the data and vertically analytics
exactly virtually and so
you know when i was working on top of
the adobe side of things and helping
people with pig and
kind of and looking at hadoop and raw
oriented storage
and it's kind of high latency and
vertica but that didn't scale as much
but was lower latency better experience
and so that kind of led into parquet so
i started prototyping something
and from my work at yahoo i was always
already
you know aware of the dremel paper
and uh i i had been when i was at ciao
had been thinking a little bit how that
would have been useful
for us at that time but i didn't really
get you kind of further than thinking
about it
and at twitter i really dug more into it
and really okay how do we convert can we
bring
more of the vertica properties into
how can we make hadoop more like vertica
and it's kind of
uh and getting getting the lower latency
the better response for queries and so
on
and that's kind of a starting
prototyping something and implementing
so the dremel paper has two parts right
there's the execution engine
aspect and then there's a storage layer
file format that they describe
and so i started like implementing the
algorithms that were described in the
paper
and and and so that's kind of led to
i had the beginning of something and i
reached out because i knew i didn't want
to build something proprietary to
twitter
and that we would have to integrate with
everything and that wouldn't make any
sense
reach out and that's where i connected
with the impala team at claddera
and they were prototyping a columnar
format
as well for impala because i mean they
were kind of following the same train of
thoughts right this kind of like
that made sense and so we joined forces
and it was a great collaboration because
uh impala being all native execution
native code execution
reno for them it was getting all the jvm
ecosystem
that this collaboration i kind of
brought all the jvm
implementation side of things and for me
like building this it brings the
validation of an actual
you know columnar query engine on top of
it right it's kind of
not just because i was hooking that up
into pig
and cascading like we're using scalding
that is built on top of this
time so that we can we could support the
twitter use cases and then they brought
the query execution
fast core execution use cases that
brought a lot of validation to the
format so we join
it's kind of we merged designs some of
the design aspects i brought some of the
design aspects they brought and that
that made the success of parquet i think
it's kind of and you and
and you open sourced it and became an
open standard yes
yes and then they originally had
different names
so we each had a name and we kind of
brainstormed a new name and that became
parque
what were the what were the names uh so
on my
end um it was called red elm
red elm radium and it's an anagram of
dremel
okay right that's what i was going for
but i was kind of
thinking oh we do the whole thing right
but actually i think it made more sense
to kind of like focus on the file format
and like enable the ecosystem there were
like so many
uh sequel and hadoop project happening
at the time
uh i think that that made a lot of sense
to have like a common
storage layer for them um rather than
building yet another one
got it so so you stayed at twitter for
a few years and then you ended up uh
probably with your closest brush maybe
to date at starting a company i assume
i mean you were very early team at
drumeo right
yeah i was i was on the you know day one
uh at the starting uh of germio so
really can't start
a new so part of the funding team uh
uh adremio and um
and so drameo was kind of going at
you know it's uh and drumeo is very
successful since then
um uh it's a there's on one aspect of it
is the federated query engine that lets
you query
all your data where it is and it has the
ability
uh to materialize um
some of the transformation so it can
like it has a smarter
uh optimizer that can take advantage of
that to speed up
your queries and you know the idea is
look you plug your tableau to your data
lake
and you get the same experience than if
you used
um you know a more um
data warehouse or a cube or something
without
without having to worry about importing
all your data like
selecting what subset you put in the in
your data warehouse like we were doing
at twitter
and i think this is what's really
related
to all the work i've been doing on
parquet and how do we optimize korea id
like part of it was the storage and
thinking about the optimizer
and it's kind of the wider query
processing aspect
and as part of that that's how we
started we started aero projects right
so it's kind of
as part of this parque community you
know the next step was to start
discussing
oh how can we have um
in-memory columnar representation so we
have as
parque we have on this culinary
presentation
but we also need an in-memory columnar
representation and it's a different
project because
you optimize things differently when you
optimize for pulling data from disk on
whether you optimize for processing in
memory
uh really fast so really the criterias
for like the layout
are very different it's still a culinary
presentation but how you pick encoding
and all of that uh is very different
because of the different characteristics
of disk and memory
and so that kind of you know
different people got connected like so
dremeo was started by the creators of
apache drill which uh sql and loop and
they had an in-memory
columnar presentation and the impala
people are saying oh we need an
in-memory columnar presentation
and so in some ways i connected people
and we started a larger group
and we say okay so how do we do this
together and so we decided
basically arrow started as spinning off
this columnar representation in drill
and refining it based on everybody's use
cases but
we started by doing a kick-off by
reaching out
to a bunch of people who had this use
case right like so
you had uh the impala people west makini
from pandas
that who was very interested about this
uh you had the dremeo folks and drill
so we contributed to that i kind of
represented also the parque community in
this aspect
and now parque in errol is very
well integrated together and is really
fast
for example ardremio uh really fast or
you know others uh it's integrated in
spark now bigquery returns
error result sets and also bigquery it's
interesting because bigquery both can
consume parquet and can produce error
result set the reason they're doing that
is because of course you can load
your bigquery result sets faster in in
pandas because um was it in
arrow well that's that's a great story
about how you
like got the community together around
this format
and um this sort of you know cross
well across the industry right from
multiple companies
um it's neat that you were essentially
able to do that twice
once with parquet and and then again
with arrow
so to be to be fair arrow piggybacked on
the parquet community as well right
start from scratch
but it's kind of i think yes it's an
iteration of like
how we build communities and it's not
exactly the same one but
i mean the motions are similar right how
do we build something
how do we own this together um
and how do we make it happen as a
community
and so then so next you went to wework
and
which um surprised me a little bit at
the time i have to say i have to be
totally honest
but i know we work with building an
amazing data engineering team
and um you know they had big visions for
for what this team was going to
accomplish
um what what was it that you learned at
wework and sort of how did your career
take the next step there
so at yeah we work i think as switch
gears a bit a little bit because i
became
uh basically the architect for the data
platform
and that was the time where wework was
growing exponentially
right so um when i joined there was
relatively
little data platform you know there was
redshift and
uh some in-house scheduler and data was
getting imported in redshift and that
was it
but in that phase there was growing um
a lot and so as part of introducing in
the ecosystems
there was like how do we ingest uh event
into kafka and enable collection
of events at scale right rather than
just importing the data that is already
in the production system um how do we
enable stream processing and batch
processing but working together right
how do we define a nice storage layer
you know using more
uh modern way of storing data in files
like iceberg
or delta lake uh that we work we picked
iceberg
um at the time so it's kind of creating
this nice foundation
and how so a much more generalist
role in that case i mean from the data
perspective of understanding what's a
data platform how do you put streaming
uh ingestion of that data stream
processing batch processing storage
layer whether it's streaming or
in data emotion or data addressed nbi
and machine learning right it's kind of
like enabling all of that
making sure schemas are defined uh
people understand how they depend on
each other
and so on right and while building that
a lot of this was okay how what do we
pick what's the best of breed
existing open source project for each of
those components like so
picking iceberg first address storage
uh in s3 picking uh you know spark
for uh batch processing um
snowflake for the warehouse and and
things like that and making sure
everything connects well together
and i think one of the big piece that
was missing in this ecosystem
is this metadata management right like
it's kind of
how do we have a lineage and metadata
repository
so this doesn't become a mess right we
know what all the data said that exist
all the jobs that exist how everything
depends on each other
so that teams have visibility right you
have many teams in the company
that consume and produce data and they
depend on each other
and they need tools to understand how
they depend on each other
and understand that they're not going to
break anything
or like or if they break something
they're aware of it
and they know how to fix things quickly
right like to to be agile
and be able to move fast as an
organization
you need to have visibility in what's
happening so that leads to the creation
of
marquez and marquez
is this lineage repository lineage and
metadata repository that keeps track
of everything that's running all the
updates to data sets
and all the dependencies right how
everything depends on each other
so that's kind of that's what the the
core of this and like enabling this data
platform
so i wanna i wanna drill into this
because um i think we arrived at
you know one of the key concepts that we
wanna talk about and so
i wanna make sure that listeners um
understand fully what you mean by uh
metadata and data lineage and also like
what the implications
um for those concepts are because i
think the things that
we're starting to become you know
slightly more familiar with as an
industry but
um i'd love to hear it from your words
um if you could just tell us like what
what is data lineage and and what does
it mean
so it's interesting because i think
depending on who you ask
you'll get very different answers to
what is lineage
right there's like one one of the
concept of lineage is like i want to
understand
how this data set is derived from others
right like oh this column
is here's the expression that produces
this metric
or how this value is derived and what
table is derived
from and from a certain perspective it's
very static
it's caring about what's the current
state of the system
how is this column derived from another
one and that's one common
uh definition of lineage another way of
looking at lineage is really to
understand
how that changes over time as well right
so i think that when you look at lineage
only from data set to data set
perspective you actually lose track of a
lot of the metadata and what's happening
because a data set especially in the
data world
exists because it's being produced by a
job
right and like the runtime
characteristics of that job and how that
changes over time
are really important to understand how
that affects the data set
so in terms of you know when we think
about
the lineage that is stored in marquez
it's trying to be very granular
and to keep track of every run of a job
and for a given run of a job
um let's say you have a recurring job
that runs every hour
right so a run would be the hourly run
of that job
and you know what version of the data
set you consume
what version of the output data set you
produced
what was the schema of the input and
output at the time it run
how long it took what was the version of
the code
uh you know if it's starting git what
was the gitcha what was
the query profile you know statistics
around performance at the time
what where you can store what were data
quality metrics
and assertion if you run like data
quality libraries on top of your output
at the time
and you keeps and you store that so now
you have lineage but
it's really at the run level or if you
look the data
uh perspective it's at the data set
version level
so you can see over time how
have uh the metadata has the metadata
change on the data set so
you know something that come in mind or
if something's broken you can care about
when did the schema change what did it
cause downstream
uh what caused this schema change
upstream maybe someone changed the logic
somewhere
um or you may care about data quality
metrics have changed suddenly we have a
drop in row count or we have an increase
in null values in a column or the
distribution
became very skewed suddenly and you know
and you can keep track
of not just how that changes over time
but really connecting that to which run
of the job
caused that change and what's and you're
saying that that's
that that you're saying that that's
absolutely required because
um having an operational view of like
how the data is being transformed
multiple times in the system
over time is key to understanding the
full lineage of that data it's not just
about like
this column is driving some other column
and some other data set somewhere
it's like if you don't take into account
the operational
changes and processing around the data
then
your your data lineage is incomplete
anyway
it sounds like that's that's what that's
the discovery that you have
yes and i think that's one of the of the
reasons we built marquez because
they were existing lineage solutions in
the market right like a linear
open source project and things but often
what they did is they focus on a
specific use case
and they collected the metadata they
cared about for that
use case and dropping on the floor a lot
of the informations we cared about
and i think one of the of the
findings of this is like by having a
really fine grain
operational metadata of course once you
know about how a data set is connected
to a job is connected to another data
set
you can transform this to remove the job
right and get the data set to data set
lineage and feed that into a system
that needs that to present other kind of
perspective on data lineage
and and so you can turn the more
fine-grained lineage into
like data set to data set lineage but
you cannot do it the offer other way
around
right so it's kind of was really
important to start collecting at the
right granularity keeping the meditative
at the job
really understanding how things get
transformed
and because that informs figuring out
all the problems we might have
with our data can you give us an example
of
like what what's a common problem that
could be solved if a company had
access to proper data lineage that they
might not even think
of in those terms yet yes
so i think you know people care about a
lot about data freshness
and data quality right so you see a lot
of solutions
that come out to solve that from a
monitoring perspective right they care
about
so when you talk about data freshness um
there's two road causes to that
one is something's broken so it's not
running anymore
and therefore the data set doesn't get
updated anymore and second
everything runs slower than usual and
the data set gets updated but it gets
updated very late so there's kind of
this freshness
uh problem and from a data quality
perspective is
the data is wrong right and this could
be
something there's been a problem at some
point uh
someone pushed a bug or there's a bad
third-party data that has been ingested
or
something happened that creating this uh
skew in the data or something
and so when you talk about data
freshness and data quality there's
a lot of things a lot of explanation
that focus
on monitoring that how do you know if
your data is correct or not
how do you know if your data is up to
date or not and so that's great right
that's about
being aware when something is wrong but
the very next step
once you know something is wrong is you
need to figure out the root cause of the
problem
the root cause of the problem is
extremely rarely
in the data you are monitoring itself
the root cause of the problem
is almost always always upstream from it
right so you may be looking at your um
you know executive dashboards that
executives in your company
like consult every morning before the
breakfast and when it's broken or it's
wrong
this is bad and but what you need to
understand
is all the lineage upstream that leads
to this dashboard you need to understand
whether a third-party data injection
that it depends on
caused the problem you need to
understand if any change
in the data pipelines in between the
ingestion of data and the delivery
of the dashboard is problematic or is
failing for some reason
so really this operational lineage are
really detailing edge of everything how
change over time
is really key to understanding why
things are slow
why things are incorrect and fixing it
quickly because i think the
main problem it takes a long time
because
when you start looking at your data then
you see the current state of things
and you don't know or it's really hard
to figure out
what has changed when correlation with
their output data being bad or
starting to become very slow to show up
so you're saying that that lineage is
the key to
a lot of common data problems and i
i think you also commented on a shared
observation that i've seen in
a bunch of the companies that i invest
in as well it's that
um you know many of these companies sort
of but
they want to solve a particular problem
right
data quality or you know monitoring
or performance of some kind
but they end up sort of backing into
their own representation
you know data cataloging but they sort
of back into their own
representation of you know metadata
as far as they need it for their for
their end solution
um but didn't start with metadata or
didn't start with lineage
they sort of start with the problem
which is a valid place for any founder
to start
but it seems like they all start to kind
many of them start to converge into the
similar
sort of you know necessary needed back
end where
they're tracking lineage and and
metadata to the extent that their
product
needs access to it and so it's been
interesting to see the
the data ecosystem sort of emerge along
that pattern in the last couple years
and it seems like you you've seen that
as well
yes so i mean it's key to understanding
the root cause of the problem and the
next thing that's really important is
start preventing problems all together
because you can identify upstream of
lineage
to find the root cause quickly but you
can also leverage downstream to prevent
you know before you're going to push a
change to production
you can validate whether it's going to
break something downstream or not right
dependencies and it's really key to you
know we talk about
data pipelines reliability of making
sure you can trust your data
like that the data is delivered on time
and it's correct
and a lot of understanding lineage to me
is really core
to uh enabling that and being more
efficient and
avoiding being in this state or
everything is always broken or worse you
don't even know if it's broken or you
don't know
what to fix first and so
you know and what impacts what is really
critical to that
yeah i totally get it um so if
if lineage is so key and if it's such a
panacea for
many of our modern data problems why is
it so difficult or challenging for
companies to implement some
sort of solution in this area like what
are the main pitfalls and the hurdles
that you see
so i think a lot of the lineage solution
that
that we see in the ecosystem they focus
on how do we extract lineage from all
those systems like people might be using
spark they might be using
using warehouses they might be using a
lot of
pandas a lot of different systems and
so they start focusing on how do i
extract lineage from each of those
things and they start depending on all
those projects
and the internals of all those projects
and really
starting being intimately dependent on
all those things
and it's first it's very complex there's
a lot of work to do this
and second it's also very brittle
because as this system changes and you
depend on their internals
they're not usually part of the official
maintained contract that needs to be
backward compatible
so all those lineage integrations first
they're expensive and complex to build
and second they need to be maintained
and they need to be re-implemented
and fixed over time and then you have to
deal with
the complexity of not just maintaining
for one
version of spark right but like for
three four version of spark like three
four versions of airflow and all those
things evolving in
parallel and there's a lot of complexity
to all of that and so it's kind of um
that's kind of what led to you know
starting
up a lineage and saying i think like the
conclusion was
we really need to solve that in the open
source right and it's not just like
i think we as engineers we have a
tendency to kind of look at systems
and see oh i can read the code i can
understand this
and i can reverse engineer it and like
produce lineage from it
but as people we actually need to talk
to each other because that leads to very
complex solutions to kind of
avoiding talking to others and and just
figuring out by yourself
and how do we and it's kind of how do we
define a standard
so that instead of everybody kind of
trying to pull the lineage out of the
internals
it's like each project can actually
publish their lineage
in a standard way and simplify this
problem
right so wait i think i think i see
where this is going
um julian is going to talk to other
people in the community
and for the third time in his career um
he's
he's going to work to create an open
standard
around lineage i sounds like i think you
just let the cat out of the bag but it
sounds like it's
actually called open lineage um so tell
me if i'm wrong
yeah so actually we started that end of
last year
um so it's kind of and i really you're
right right i took a card out of the
um arrow playbook and
there was this conclusion it was like
look each
um you know there's a need for multiple
products that ex
exploit lineage and like it's presented
for different use cases whether people
care about data catalog they care about
operation they care about governance
compliance
they all need lineage but they have
different use cases so they need
different solutions on how to look at
that
however the lineage collection and like
having this fine-grained understanding
of dependencies this is all
widely applicable and everybody needs it
and it would be much easier
if we could define a standard and we
could say well this is a standard way
people
expose lineage and consume lineage and
so that instead of having this
complexity and maintaining different
integration for each of the projects
that care about lineage
um we can just like have a standard
and you know it remove duplication of
efforts and everything is less brittle
because each project can actually expose
their own internal in a
lineage or metadata in a standard way
and there is
a standard way of doing that that we
maintain and it's not
changing all the time right so that
so we did like arrow right we kind of
started reaching out to people in the
community that were interested in that
kind of thing
and like 90 of the
projects we reach out to were like of
course we need a standard lineage right
like
like how come does it not exist already
like it's been like i don't know like 15
years from my perspective
how come we don't have a standard
lineage yet well
the thing is for it to happen we need to
plant the seed we need to come together
and say like okay let's do this
and push it and create a focal point
where we can standardize this and make
it happen
so that's kind of that's what we did so
like open lineage
uh we started kind of like relatively
small community
you know reaching out to people uh
from dbt from air flow community
from prefect from pandas from spark
from uh munson algeria
it's kind of reaching out to an uh great
expectation and i apologize i'm like
forgetting people
but like getting together and talk about
what's the right way to do this
um and started up a lineage and actually
last week it's also officially been
submitted to the lfi and data so this is
the
sub-foundation of the linux foundation
you know like the sister to
ncf but for so it's like the cncf for
data world
okay great that's great that's so that's
very cool development
yeah so just so it's just um it just
happened so
it's like you know it's like arrow the
goal is it's not a project that is owned
by anyone
it's really something that we need as an
industry
as a data ecosystem we need another way
to do this we need to build that
and um and the more people contribute to
it the more everybody gets out of it
right so that's right good open source
motions
i think for that kind of project uh that
helps build momentum
and creating this uh open source
flywheel
of um of getting adoption like you've
seen in
parquet and arrow it's kind of like
there's lots of value of trying to build
those standards in open source
i just uh we just added a link to the
openly lineage project in the youtube
chat so that folks can check it out
um so before we talk a little bit more
about you know in-depth
um about some of the architecture and
design principles of open lineage
i just wanted to like clarify one thing
because
um i know that you were working on
marquez which was
um you know sort of an original data
lineage project at wework and
um you and willy have spoken about that
at data council in years past
um so i just want to understand sort of
generally speaking
like what's the difference between
marquez and the new open lineage project
just so that we create the right space
in people's minds in terms of
comparison contrast yeah so
you know marquez is a lineage repository
a lineage and metadata repository and
um as i have mentioned before you know
like one of the findings is like
well they're very different use cases to
uh
inspecting lineage or presenting lineage
like whether we talk about governance or
data catalogs
and each system really wants to be able
to store it and index it
in the way they care about right
depending on their use case so people
care also that
privacy engineering is another use case
that people care about
and so and there was this uh conclusion
that oh there's many projects that
care about extracting lineage from other
systems
uh and so there's lots of duplication of
effort and this is hard
and so on right so open lineage it's
it's really and it's kind of came from
the realization of we need something
like
open telemetry but for data pipelines
so open telemetry is a cncf project
and what it does it's standardizing
metrics and traces and log collection
for services right like in traces for
services
is really similar to lineage for data
pipeline
right except of course like services and
data pipelines work differently so you
need kind of
its own api but
there's a strong parallel of defining a
standard for collection
that then can be leveraged by many tools
whether it's open source project
or third-party vendors or various other
things
so really opening edge focused on just
defining
the standard for collection of this
lineage
and then you can have multiple consumers
you know and marquez
is the reference implementation of it so
marquez
uh is a open lineage consumption
endpoint
and openly is an api on
how you emit and consume
uh those open lineage events so that you
understand
really at the run level and very
granular
lineage information so it's kind of that
was openly images open lineage
is a standard for lineage collection
and marquez is a reference
implementation and of course
uh there are others um who um
working on uh implementing uh
open it okay that that helps yeah thanks
for clarifying that
um so so what are some of the core
design principles of open
lineage like how do you go about
thinking through how to build something
like this
yeah so i think one of the goal from my
experience building those
uh open you know standards in the open
source and it's kind of
it's not it's a bit different like we're
not like uh a standard body
right like it's not like there's not
much i've been appointing and it kind of
meeting
us and kind of work for a long time on
having a big monolithic spec
but really the idea is in open source
it's really good to decompose
every atomic decision like really have
their own conversation and their own
life cycle and you really want to avoid
have a big monolithic spec that defines
everything
and so what we did so starting with this
core group
of people who were excited about like
working on open lineage we started with
making this
course back which is really what's the
minimal thing
we can define that collects lineage
and how do we make it extensible so you
can add various pieces of metadata that
different people
care about for various use cases right
so the core model of open image is very
simple
there's a notion of recurring job that
is identified by the um
unique name that's running like your
typical hourly jobs or daily jobs or
monthly job
but it can be various other things right
there's a notion of run
so there's a run id of like this is an
instance of this job running
and then there's notion of inputs and
outputs so you have a
run of a job that is reading from this
input data set
and writing to this output data set and
same thing having it has a consistent
naming policy
so that we can stitch this lineage back
together and like two different system
will call this data set the same thing
and so this is the core and it's just
capturing the lineage and it's
very simple and and so we that's the
first thing we did as a group is like
let's solidify this
this is the core and on top of that
there's this notion of facet
and a facet is kind of an atomic piece
of metadata so each facet
is its own little spec right it's all
defined using json schema
to sp uh um specify what the fields are
what's the representation and so you can
attach
facets to the job through the run to the
data set
and so on uh on the data set for example
it could be the data set uh schema at
the time
the job run right so you can track
whether the schema has changed
uh and what change its schema it could
be
data quality metrics at the data set
level you know what was the row count
what was the number of null count for
each uh column like
or distribution or things like that if
you implement something like great
expectations for example
um and then at the run level you make
stores things like
what's the query profile uh for this
particular run how long it took
um what was the at the job level which
could
capture what's the verge their version
in source control of the job and keeping
track so you can start correlating
changing the output schema with what was
the version of the job
and and stitching back the lineage
together so it's kind of the facets or
the facets so if there's three core
um types there's job run
and data set you mentioned and then the
facet can be added to any one of those
three
to sort of further define specific
metadata for that particular instance
is that the general idea that's a
general idea and so the core model is
very generic
and the idea is also so first you can
add optional metadata depending on the
context that may or may not be available
you may or may not
have a schema depending on what you have
and also you have different types of
data set
right a data set could be a folder in an
s3 bucket
it could be a table in the data
warehouse
it could be a topic in a kafka broker
right so it's kind of
and depending on their type like this
they will have different facets
right you have different pieces of
metadata you track differently what was
the version
of the data set from one to the other
right if you use the version
data storage like a delta lake or
iceberg for example
you can keep track of what actual
version was produced by this run right
which lets you really easily
roll back using time travel like the
features of
uh storage layer provide to roll back to
the previous version
if something goes wrong right the worst
case scenario is not when the job fails
the worst case scenario is when the job
run produce bad data
and you provide it all through your
stack right so that's kind of like the
kind of thing you can track
through that so so what's the result of
the project been so far
um how are you measuring success or
are you aware of how many folks are
adopting um the core principles behind
open lineage so far
yeah so the the progress so far so we
defined the initial spec
we started defining uh facets so you
have we have some core facets that are
defined and
marquez of course is a reference
implementation so anybody will
want to consume open lineage can use
markets for this
we have integration so it's kind of the
goal eventually is to be pushed in every
project
as a dependency and you know it's like
just adding an interface
right and you can uh emit information to
it
and it's not like it's relatively easy
to integrate because it doesn't add any
other extra dependency to your project
right it's just
an api with no dependencies and
um it's like a logger really like
perspective
it's like tracing and so we have
integration at the moment for airflow
for bigquery for spark
for a snowflake uh great expectation
uh and there's a prototype of like dbt
uh
integration on the consumption side i
think the most advanced project
is the aegeria project so ageria is this
open metadata project
and so they'd be working on also being
able to consume
open image and be able to also ride it
so it's kind of
edgier is a bit like a metadata bus that
lets you kind of
push your metadata to other things so it
kind of makes sense to be able to
consume and produce open image and
connect things together as well
um oh and and the other aspect of facet
um that i didn't mention so one of the
goal is to remove friction
from the project right like so
avoid uh um
having tightly coupled decisions right
like decoupling facet decoupled decision
making and so we can move fast on things
that are less controversial
and things that are more controversial
kind of more focused discussion and
conclusion and the other thing we added
is this notion of custom facet
so actually anybody can attach a facet
that is not part of the spec
and publish their own definition of a
facet and the idea is
it really it makes it really easy for
people to experiment
and like create their own facet without
having to go through getting it approved
by the project
like you can really make your own facets
and and be able to
uh to add to it and i think there are
two values to this one is kind of
really unblocking people as much as much
as possible they can experiment with
that to ask for permission for anything
and second it's a great way to collect
what people are doing with it to kind of
start
bubbling up right under the way to
represent certainty the actual spec
right yeah so um that's that's really
cool those are some really interesting
um design principles um
that's uh yeah that's that's that's
great julian um it sounds like a really
interesting project
i'm curious like if if somebody wants to
dip their toe in the water with open
lineage like
what's the quickest easiest way to get
started
because sometimes i think the fear
behind these kinds of
um projects that have like such a strong
sort of philosophical
or you know opinionated bent is like
do you have to commit whole hog to it to
actually get value from it
um so like what's what's the what's the
best way for people to think about that
and that trade-off like what does that
look like for open lineage what's the
smallest way to get started
so i think the easiest is probably to
uh stand up a marquez instance right
and start um collecting open image so
you can use it in existing integration
so if you use airflow
if you use uh spark if you use bigquery
snowflake you can start like
uh hooking that into your airflow and
setting up an image event to
a marquez instance for example and see
the lineage
and marquez also has a lineage
api that you can script it as well right
you can query the
rest api and there's a graphql api for
people who like this kind of thing
to kind of explore the lineage or build
on top of it
and if you want to integrate
things that are not integrated yet right
like so there's a
json schema spec uh that is relatively
easy to use and um we we
have a python client and the java client
in the works which makes it easy so
depending on if you're interested in
introspecting what you have and see see
in markets what this looks like
or whether you're interested in
making your own integration right it's
all about producing json events
uh and there's a clients that help you
doing that right so once you have json
schemas
really json schema is the underlying
object representation for open api for
people who are used to open api
and generating code for models and
exposing like this
uh it's relatively easy way um
to push the model right so we we have a
python client that's
based on that and a java client um
that lets you easily produce your
metadata in that space
got it and of course people can find
full
documentation on github and
they can get in touch with you you have
the
illustrious j underscore handle on
twitter
um that we always hear about in the
community so i'm sure
this are a slack group for open lineage
or any community like that
the best way to reach out is probably to
join the uh slack
uh channels so if you open lineage
github
um you'll find a link to the slack right
open image
slack open lineage twitter and all the
open lineage uh
github organization so it's relatively
easy to
to find so yeah please join the uh
the slack feel free to ask questions um
and uh and uh yeah we're very happy to
help and answer questions
and there's some some focused um
discussion uh channels as well in there
okay okay great yeah that's good to know
well julian we're almost out of time but
i just wanted to ask you a final
question
um which is what are the big insights
that you've learned
over your career working with data
um i think like working on those open
source maybe i'll reuse
some of those um analogy you know like
engineers like to reverse engineer stuff
more than
talking to others or like spending time
figuring out
and so i think that's kind of one of the
key finding
and that open lineage
is a people problem more than a
technical problem it's about
getting together and agreeing
on some key principles and like making
it so much easier
to build these things right so i think
it's there's this notion of stone soup
right i don't know if you know these
stone soup children's story
like someone comes from a village and
they go to on the
on the main town uh square
and they have a big pot of hot water and
they put
a large stone in it and they start
steering and like people ask them what
are you doing
i'm preparing a stone soup for everyone
but
you're welcome to run your own
ingredients so basically they're making
a soup
of nothing right it's just hot water and
the stone is just
like um a dummy thing to say look i put
an ingredient
and start steering it so i'm just
enabling the community
right and people bring their own
ingredients like okay let me add carrots
to it let me add leaks to it whatever
and then start steering and the more
people contribute to it the more this
thing becomes
better for everyone so it's kind of you
know that's what i'm doing
i'm steering the pot and i think there's
so much you can achieve by
enabling others right how do we get
together how do we own this as a
community
how do we make it make sense for all of
us it's kind of you know
building this open source momentum right
like and the more people contribute the
more there's value into it the more
people contribute
and you know you've seen that happening
for parque and you've seen that
happening for arrow
and yes it takes years but it happened
right and once it
started it's kind of unstoppable right
like uh
you know today if i wanted to stop
parking i you know like
i couldn't how yeah there's nothing to
do
yeah well that's that's really well said
poetic even
and it's been great to um collaborate
with you
um through data council over the last
few years
we've definitely appreciated uh you you
coming and sharing in forums like this
and that are
our live conferences so it's been great
to get to know you julian and
um i appreciate you stirring the pot i
hope that you you
keep it up you're right that engineers
aren't always good at sort of building
um talking to each other and and sort of
using collaboration to build standards
like this so
yeah thanks for all your work in the
community and um it was really great to
have you
chat with us today you're welcome it was
a pleasure thank you have a great day
and uh to the rest of the community
thanks for joining us
um please subscribe to the youtube
channel so that you can stay abreast of
some more amazing dc thursdays episodes
that we have coming up across the summer
so take care and we'll see you soon